Netflix is a vast sea of entertainment
options so many in fact that you may
feel like you're drowning in
possibilities we get it it can overwhelm
even the most experienced to binge-watch
er but don't worry because we're here to
throw you a cinematic lifeline with
unappreciated gems on Netflix that you
just have to watch moonrise kingdom
described as an eccentric pubescent love
story by The Hollywood Reporter moonrise
kingdom is definitely the most romantic
movie on director Wes Anderson's resume
this coming-of-age tale has a great cast
including Tilda Swinton Bruce Willis
Edward Norton and Bill Murray
and it also boasts a beautiful setting
as well as all the quirky hallmarks that
Anderson fans have come to love
Nightcrawler suspenseful and visually
stunning this oscar-nominated thriller
features Jake Gyllenhaal in a creepily
convincing performance as a sociopath
freelance videographer tasked with
uncovering the late-night crime beat for
local news stations we find our viewers
are more interested in urban crime
creeping into the suburbs what that
means as a victim or victims preferably
well-off wait
the performance landed Gyllenhaal a
Golden Globe nomination for Best Actor
while the screenplay for Nightcrawler
earned an Oscar nomination for writer
Dan Gilroy Tucker and Dale vs. evil the
thing we love about Tucker and Dale vs.
evil is how it turns traditional horror
tropes on their head this comedy horror
film stars alan tudyk and Tyler Labine
as a pair of West Virginia hillbillies
to encounter a group of clueless college
students on a camping trip when one of
the college students accidentally hurts
herself the hillbillies take care of her
until the misguided college kids attempt
to rescue her from what they assume are
scary backwoods Hicks all sorts of
hilarious and horrific hijinks ensue
which makes this movie a perfect choice
for Netflix cue
in your eyes this just weed and jam
tells the story of two very different
people
a married socialite from New Hampshire
and an ex-con from New Mexico who have
shared an inexplicable mental connection
since childhood that neither understands
as the connection deepens they realize
they aren't going crazy because there is
actually another person inside their
heads but while they know they're sane
the rest of the world isn't so sure the
way back based on a memoir by a former
Polish prisoner of war the way back
tells the incredible story of a group of
POWs who escaped from a Siberian gulag
and walk over four thousand miles
crossing deserts and even the Himalayas
in an epic quest to find freedom this
change is serving
there's nowhere to hide its also
features amazing cinematography as well
as a stellar cast including Colin
Farrell and Oscar nominees Edie Harris
and Saoirse Ronan old boy while an
American version of old boy directed by
Spike Lee was released in 2013 the
original south korean movie is far
superior and it's on Netflix for your
viewing pleasure based on a Japanese
manga old boy is a thrilling neo-noir
mystery centred on the story of a man
who was abducted and held for 15 years
in a prison cell with no knowledge of
who his captors are or why they are
keeping him there learn to walk more Abu
anga coochie mah nà no luck then he
finds himself suddenly released and
given the chance to get revenge on his
captors if he can find them in a mere
five days and then well we can't say
anything else about spoiling the many
shocks on surprises kung fury funded
entirely by Kickstarter kung fury
debuted at the Cannes Film Festival
before being released free of charge on
YouTube where it gained such a cult
following that it's secured
international distribution on Netflix as
crazy as that story is though it pales
in comparison to the utterly insane 80s
action parody mashup that installs on
your screen with everything from
time-traveling demigods to dinosaur cops
- kung fu Hitler kung fury delivers a
knockout blow to your funny bone that
you may never recover from sorry I
doubted you Chris Sharrock up YouTube is
tempered never had I came back in time
for you kung fury because dammit I love
you these final hours with only 12 hours
left before an asteroid induced global
firestorm which hits Australia a dude
named James abandoned his pregnant
girlfriend in search of the ultimate
apocalyptic party along the way though
the self-indulgent and arrogant James
meets a young girl and discovers he has
some serious choices to make about how
he truly wants to spend his last moments
on earth forgive me thinking
but what I'm gonna do since edgy and raw
these final hours show us the best and
worst of humanity when pushed to the
brink be prepared for an edge of your
seat ride that will also inspire tears
and deep thoughts about what you would
do if you only had 12 hours left to live
which is easy just eat as much pizza as
possible centaurian at first glance
centaurian looks like another vanilla
sword and sandals war epic which is
probably why it absolutely tanked at the
box office when it was released in 2010
but it be ashamed for any fan of bloody
action to pass on this hidden gem
because Centurion definitely delivers
much more than it promises focusing on a
tiny band of Roman soldiers trapped in
enemy territory as they tried to make
their way home michael fassbender leads
the cast through every blood-soaked
battle while Neil Marshall who is best
known for directing some of the most
popular episodes of Game of Thrones ever
is behind the camera so sit back relax
and watch a bunch of people kill each
other what else are you going to do
while you wait for the next season of
Thrones thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to